each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
alright welcome so it's great to
introduce the session on privacy in
context I'm Ben Zorn I co-managed the
research and software engineering group
here in microsoft research in redmond
i'm really happy to talk about privacy
today i think it's one of the most
important topics it's on a lot of
people's minds a lot of things in the
news are making us aware that
information about us is being stored in
places and being used and accessed in
ways that we didn't expect and i think
today we're going to hear about some of
the technologies and ideas that take
this work forward and really give us a
greater sense of privacy we start with j
in june who got her PhD at MIT in 2006
she worked in tablets in seattle until
2011 where steep line MSR and she works
in the areas of privacy mobile systems
and vices for the home and she's going
to talk today about teens and parents
perspective on surveillance so please
welcome Jen thank you well thank you ok
so this presentation is based on this
kind of exploratory research that I did
with these two wonderful collaborators
blaze is he's a student at Carnegie
Mellon and store is sitting there and
you know if you want to look at zero
fools full paper you can go that URL and
then look at it but today i I just I
want this I'm hoping that this would be
some kind of conversation rather than be
telling you what we found because this
is just kind of I feel that this is a
kind of very interesting sort of
observation that we made but we have
been through you know found solutions
for this problem ok so the context smart
for a smart home of the future I don't
know where there's some of you have been
to Microsoft's envisioning center but we
have that wonderful like in a room in
the next building that you can see kind
of this futuristic kind of home that
some of them are a wizard of oz I guess
it's on purpose
they're just gonna they're showing
you know what can be done like in
regardless of technologies existing out
there in any case so this is like a one
it's picture of this envisioning home
showing that these guys they're cooking
and then this like smart cooktop is
showing the recipe and then he can also
talk to the chef like through a
microphone and stuff so this is kind of
one imagination of smart home of the
future shook and so we're not there yet
but I don't know like maybe some of you
into like that spy on those places but
there are lots of through now smart
devices coming to the market and that's
the Philips this is Hugh is a color
changing light bulb and nest thermostat
and this is like a video doorbell and
the programmable dola these are just a
few examples but there are like really a
lot of devices coming to the market with
a sort of connectivity to the internet
and improve programmability so you know
it's very exciting and good lots of
devices but I'm going to throw narrow
them down into those a few kind of home
security related devices so then it's
for instance this is like a like you
know those so two devices among those
and those are kind of peeling to cost
customers little Marcus it because you
know as you can see there's a kind of
clear benefit of these devices it's not
just something that you know I don't
know that makes your house cool right
but you know it's very clear benefit of
you know you can with this door lock you
with a keypad you no longer need to
carry your key and you don't have to
worry about your being locked out and
also with this kind of connected no
video doorbell you can also do kind of
remotely through monitoring the food is
that your doorstep and so on so this is
great and not just this in with those
devices you can really secure your home
so this is
this is just our mock-up but you know
you can imagine with those devices like
doorbell and connected to all apps and
security cameras you can really find out
like who is coming you're who is that
your doorstep at what time and you know
with whom and all these things I mean
this can be really awesome and actually
some of those devices they use these as
a 1-up like this kind of auditing
feature as a sort of marketing selling
point so this is good right oh and then
there's all kind of additional benefits
of having this detailed security locks
are from those smart smart devices in
the home but as the title alluded this
audit logs can also reveal so things
that you might not want your household
members to know so for instance like
teenagers arriving home after curfew or
in on my weekend I guess not at night
maybe not but you know when your parents
are away maybe sneaking in friends or at
night sneaking out this could be all
capture but this kind of security logs
and also let's say that you know you
bring you bought something like you know
surprise gift for your children and then
maybe that's captured by this camera and
then it could be now if that kind of log
is available to anyone in the household
then there may be no longer surprised
right now I don't want to go with like
off like domestic affairs and stuff but
you could imagine that you know this
kind of solution design for home
security can cause some some of the
privacy issues in the hole okay and next
so you know there could be lots of
issues but in this study we focused on
the impact of these systems and the
relationship of between teenagers and
parents so teenagers we all go through
that stage right and we all desire
freedoms you know also this is the kind
of age that people throw try to like
push the boundaries
a bit now they feel like they're adults
you know they should do you know they're
on their own way without parents without
getting approvals from parents and then
a parent's right you know that's the
time that your parents texts are really
getting worried about teenagers and also
you know also in other parents are the
ones that will worry more about home
security right you know these are the
people I guess what the people who have
to pay mortgage and also and if
something gets stolen then it is a
parents who have to pay okay so what's
kind of specifically what do we do for
this issue so these are the two kind of
big research questions that we want you
to explore so what is like I said what's
the impact of this kind of in-home
surveillance technologies or monitoring
security modern technologies on
parenting relationship and then the
second one is in if there is an impact
that impact is there anything that we
can do so as a through you know people
who are designing on these systems I
from either like an interfaces interface
design or this kind of some kind of
technical solutions is there anything
that we can do to reduce negative impact
so those are the two research questions
that we explored and then for the number
one we started with a user study so we
recruited participants we recruited 13
teenagers do those who are entering like
9th to 11th well frayed and then 12
parents of teenagers but note that these
parents of teenagers and due diligence
they are not not from the same household
in the VD did intentionally and i'll
splain this later why we did it and then
what we did was we brought those people
those ads participants to building 99
for an hour of interview and then that
was done like two years ago and then we
used kind of parallel scripts for
teenagers
I mean these questions that we asked
teenagers you know some of them are the
same questions but some of them are in
our like the teenagers is from that from
their perspective and parents in the
front parents perspective kind of police
in this kind of parallel way and then
after we did this study we analyze this
interview and every interview was all
recorded and transcribed and then we
used this in standard through methods
for qualitative data analysis okay so
let's say that you know you are my
participants like so you're here you're
in this conference room like you know
maybe you're talking to me or stored or
place and what we did was we first
showed this commercially available do
lots this tag so we got a few
advertising materials of those connected
door locks so the thing is so we're
trying to recruit participants who
already so head so use those and door
locks and connected to locks and cameras
and so on but there are not many of them
who already and a half those installed
in their home and so we so to help them
through you know familiar rice with the
system we asked them to look at this you
know the this marketing materials and
then and then we talked about sort of
you know the pros and cons of you know
those like 20 lakhs and stuff and then
we will show them so 30 possible
interfaces of auditing those auditing
those security events in the house and
then we asked them to choose which one
that they would like to have in their
home and then you know after after they
they made a choice and it will be
displayed a discussion about you know
this choice and then we also asked
people about you know through--the
existing so methods that they used
monitor their kids activities and so on
so that's kind of the roughly the
structure of the interview
oh and so the few kind of methodology
through highlights we when we recruited
participants and then also you know when
we presented these materials remember
the conversation we never mentioned
privacy we just said that this is the
study of us smart homes so not to prime
these participants and oh and then
before we saw benighted design this
study and we were not on experts of
these parenting relationships but we
found out that there's a huge literature
like in social studies about logistic
looking at this parent parent in
relationships and also parenting styles
and all these things so so reviewed some
of those and then we saw we also came up
with those questionnaires I guess we
also use the questionnaires that were
recommended by those experts to to
assess kind of their parenting style and
so on so that was also part of the
interview and then a number three so
this teen participants they had in a not
all all of those also this is the one of
the rules of this interviewing the
students you need we need to we needed
to get parents consent so in this
teenager when they came to our study the
parent came you know came along and they
had to like sign consent and so on right
and so first of all you know we wanted
to throw tech those 15 participants
right so these parents knew and the sum
of the teen participants were children
of our colleagues so yeah it's when
those people who read our paper right
and then we want it to really protect
those participants so I guess it as you
will see in later on so we kind of
anonymize their quotes and so on so that
we can protect their identity and also
but because of that read also because of
the reasons we didn't use these parents
and teens from a same household right
because if you have
and parents would know that what kind of
questions that they're you know
teenagers would have been asked to
answer them because reprove them for
that okay next oh and then participant
demographics you know it's really kind
of age and gender distribution you can
read from that and the household
competition we didn't try to expel lence
on that but we got we got sort of a
little divers kind of participants like
there's a there's a teenager who lived
with her body and that with a parent and
there were there were few single parents
and there were participants who who live
with their significant others and
although we didn't get participants who
have this never been using this smart
door laughs and stuff these are mostly
most of them were very technical
technologically savvy so this day so
when they looked at this in a door or
lock up advertising mature says oh yeah
I've seen this on TV or oh you know my
friend has this or you know like that
that kind of thing so that was good for
us okay so you know this is kind of this
is the brought the marketing material
that people the participant it to the
participants and this is a question that
we asked it depends of how would you
feel about having this kind of
internet-connected door locks installed
in your house and what features would
you use and anything that and then if
they will answer you know like some of
some features right and then we ask you
know anything that concerns you or or
other members of the household you know
if you were to have this kind of doula
so we asked this question and many
participants day so thought that is all
acts are feeling these are convenient
and this is new they sort of got this
right away and this kind of automation
capabilities you know people sort of
came up with a rule like right on the
spot and also be nice
if nadal that whenever do like the Texas
someone's home and an AC gets turned on
or something like they were turned off
whenever the door gets locked or
something and then only like three of
the participants that is not that
interesting ok and then so although they
are generally they like these features
some of them had concerns if they can
usability and reliability like you know
how about if I forget the code and what
if you know the this thing loses Wi-Fi
connectivity what if that you know then
how would I get into the home and so on
oh and interestingly a lot of people but
many of the participants were worried
about hacking as a concern and since
it's a connected you know what happens
if it gets hacked and so on oh and then
there's some participant actually like
mentioned this shorter surfing attack
but they didn't use the term but in a
central that's what they said oh and
then also some of your participants were
worried about this pin code sharing I
mean the key of course you know you can
you know duplicate a key and so on
button it's a kind of more of a hassle
but the code is much easier to share
right so it was a they're worried about
Arnold unauthorized access unauthorized
sharing code with unauthorized people ok
and then so after so participants at a
time to really sort of thing through of
you know this pros and cons of this door
locks we ask this question so if your
family were to install internet
connected do lots which of these three
kind of security interfaces would you
like to have and why so number one
option is fotolog look at it and number
two the option is text logs so the
difference is it doesn't show these
pictures at the doorstep and then number
three it's no lock so you know maybe you
don't you don't want this kind of lock
so let me just
so to a straw polling what would you
like so how many of you want to have a
photo log 12 okay let's say the 10 and
the text lock I don't know five and no
log about 56 okay and then like draw
right participants so all 11 pounds they
say they prefer photo locks and then
they said that the reason is for safety
oh and like one person said oh you could
see who actually been in the most time
and you know I also want to verify you
know he's my son is coming coming home
alone or not right it's kind of safety
reasons and then among this 11 however
three so mentioned about some some
concerns about surveillance especially
persaud apparent to said it's just a
human nature thing that nobody likes
when people keep tabs on anybody but the
thing to notice is although these people
mentioned this concerns and then they
say oh and my kid kids might not like it
if I if we had these systems with a 40
law but nonetheless they chose to have
photo lock and then teens what would you
think that teens would have chosen okay
so six out of forgot maybe 13 so they
chose 40 lakhs I'm a beast seem to be a
very good short ah good good tin with
good children they say oh you know this
is for the same reason I like to see
kind of to make for the safety of the
home and then three chose text logs and
saying that all in a camera is not
necessary you know it's like a photo
with photos this seems like invasion of
privacy like kind of Big Brother kind of
thing so the privacy was a prison and
then for teens they say no loss and like
my favorite quote is this is like
parents going psycho all right like no
way okay so now we see kind of this kind
of differences right so potentially this
could cause tensions
oh and then we also add some questions
about this is only to the this is to the
parents about notifying children on data
collection so so this is about so you
know if this is really about
surveillance right you know when we so
talk about privacy and we say when you
have surveillance system at least you
should notify that something is going on
right but this is kind of their like
privacy one-on-one so we asked you know
whether parents who think this way and
but like nine out of 11 they said
positively said okay so yeah I'll let my
children know that you know we our our
home has this system but this afford at
patoot or two parents that know like you
know one person said oh in a trust but
verify you know that's kind of the moto
that I have right so this person and
then right so she wants to she's a
single parent and then she said and she
wanted to verify everything her son says
to her through this and so after going
through this through exercise we asked
about we asked our participants about
you know there are some existing
activities and one is about you do your
children have a coffee or daily time
limit for using computer and so on and
do you know their Facebook passwords and
those are the questions and do more
online activities and are your Facebook
friend with your child this these are
the kind of questions that we asked and
be the parents so they said you know
there's kind of their practices they put
computer family computer in the living
room and so that they can throw you know
take a look what's going on so that's
kind of the best practice right now and
then many of them through complained
about kind of the onion text kind of
usability issues of those parental
control features of browser and so on oh
and then texting was a big issue
so for teens they say they're texting
and it is very their private data they
don't want their parents to go through
all this but there are many parents who
said you know they have they feel that
they have a right to go through text the
text of of their children if there's
some issues coming up oh and then so we
also ask only to the teen participants
whether they had any instances weather
day to try to circumvent circumvent
parents rules or they know anyone else
who is doing it it was very interesting
like a one a teenager said oh you know
if he goes his girlfriend house a lot
and then he said if his girlfriend's
parents and install this kind of system
then you know he said all have to yell
like Oh Rapunzel all so that he can
throw climb up rather than going through
a door and then and then there's some
some teen participant mentioned oh yeah
I know a friend who has this kind of
system home system but you know what and
if you put this the context sensor like
on some metal it doesn't work so they
know how to disable the systems and then
they're actively doing it so the lessons
answer it's a kind of very it is of this
at this paper is a lot of kind of very
interesting kind of juicy codes but
lesson number one is so currently there
are few systems that provide this kind
auditing logs but it doesn't give a
customer's choice right of granularity
of log in and so on its kind of days
it's marketed at parents and so what we
are saying is you know if this kind of
system were to become really popular
then it could cause tension between
teens and parents and secondly and not
just that not just causing some tensions
and it would result in can reduce
security because you know like i said
the children would try to circumvent
this or try to throw this able some some
of these things so the big lesson from
this this thing is you know teens are
not your typical adversary right you
can't really design a system but you can
really apply the system design forward
into this kind of
attackers and bad guys and then just to
apply this to in the homes home setting
and so so these are the roof kind of
lessons now what can we do and so we
talked about a few ideas there so in
terms of kind of interface design so
these are some of the ideas that we
discussed in some kind of coarse-grained
logging and also giving teen some sort
of notifications whenever this kind of
alert gets generated through parent and
so on so these are things that kind of
be interesting to explore and then as a
future work up quick we had kind of tool
through looking at at that point one is
so the thing is this kind of attitudes
of privacy changes over time and over
technology and so you know what's the
kind of how this changeover times that
would be kind of interesting to see with
some large-scale study and the second
one is and if this study is about it I
so like in the lab you just ask them
questions and you'll be really
fascinating to see how this kind of
audit logs are use or abuse or
circumvented in practice so that's
another thing okay so times up and I'm
done okay we have a few minutes for
questions so if you have a question i
guess i'll give you the do we have a
second Mike okay him any questions so
let me ask the first question so do you
have such a device on your home and if
so how do you set the lot of the logging
features high so that's a good question
so I have a story and I we have nine
year old and six year old so there are
not teenagers yet and we have a drop cam
and so it's facing outside we are not
capturing anything so the since our kids
are younger they don't seem to mind at
all that I can see like whenever someone
is at the door step and so on so I have
a full access and then it's like a photo
log right so but I don't know how this
thing will change
my kids right become old Yuri like in
quantum physics the measuring changes
the world so I suspect that these teen
teenagers would give different answers
to their friends in you know relaxing
with a beer then to you oh yeah that's a
really good question so so one of the
interviewers was the intern student
plays so he is much younger than and I
and we were served we were telling him
and also he tried to kind of be friendly
to this teen participants and then we
asked them and then at the end of
interview we told them you know to tell
us anything that they are not
comfortable sharing with us and so we're
just trying to create a sort of
situation that is mixed teens
comfortable to talk to us yeah but
that's a good question right
there may have been the fraction is
fairly small but did say anything there
okay let's thank the speaker